what was the strategy you had before you
made your first movie and how did that
strategy change for your second film
okay
first movie it was just about getting it
out
and with the first movie you're like oh
this is going to be on Netflix it's
gonna you're so optimistic and you need
that optimistic to carry you through
your career
but the main thing about it was I had to
prove to myself that I can get it done
so the strategy on the first one there
was no strategy it was like hey let's
make this movie
so I made the movie and I kind of winged
it the whole movie was just winged I did
create a shot list and everything and
realized I didn't use anything on the
shot list so now I don't even create
shot lists uh I I look at the space that
I have available to me and then I shoot
accordingly so with the first film it
was just about making it right
with the second film
I knew that I went from step one if if
Rex Park was step one I knew four Amigos
was step 20 and I knew that's how I
wanted to take it
so I had to plan a little more
so first my thought process and I'll go
over through the whole the whole thought
process and let me just say this to any
filmmaker out there
your film
no matter if it has a million dollar
budget a zero dollar budget or five
hundred thousand dollar budget
associated with it your film will be
judged against other high-level
Hollywood films with massive budgets
with a talented crew it doesn't matter
it's always going to be judged against
that because the viewer that's what they
watch and that's what they know and
that's what they're used to so they're
always going to judge your film against
that so with four Amigos
I knew right away
I had to up my game
I had to get better and I had to do
better so first I wrote the script
that I broke down the scenes
then I applied locations to scenes
then I started getting the cash together
about who was going to play what
and then we we stretched it out right
so once we had all that in place I
procured locations I got insurance for
those locations when we shot because it
was a much greater film and then I got
the drivers the drivers came from my my
months and months and months of
procuring drivers emails their cars
listing that out and getting that email
list ready
then once all of that was planned I have
my black magic I have my 24 through 105
mil lens I had my really powerful light
I had a shoulder rig and I had a Sheen
Weevil s gimbal that had no business
holding the black magic pocket cinema
camera right it had it wasn't strong
enough
but it's what I had and it's what I used
so the shoulder rig was used for all and
this was a cheap 60 eBay shoulder rig
that was used to shoot
all of the talking shots
everything else was all gimbal lighting
we had our crew we had the actors we had
the locations we had everything set and
then we just pounded away and shot and
shot and shot and shot now you have to
know that when you're shooting if you're
a filmmaker if you shoot 6K 3-1
you're gonna run out of storage really
fast and then you have to ask yourself
how much storage do you have at home to
transfer your footage because it's
almost impossible for me anyways to edit
footage on an external hard drive that's
6K raw going to your PC so because I
knew that I shot a 6K
cropped uh at five to one so that gave
me a little bit of space took the bit
rate down a little bit and I had more
storage for the film
then as I shot scenes I would edit the
scenes as I shot
so anytime I had a day off if I shot on
a Sunday I would edit on a Saturday if I
shot on a Saturday I'd edit on a Sunday
and then that way as the film neared its
completion all the scenes were already
done and then I just had to put them in
their sequence
and then that allowed for efficiency
so then once all of that was shot you're
working on post-production now
let me say this
always know when it comes to film
visuals are what you see sound is what
you feel
so sound design is to me more important
than the visuals because you can shot
something that's shot excellent lit well
performance as well but if the audio is
not good it's almost unwatchable but if
you have a film where it's shot decent
but the audio is Sublime
you can watch it now if you can get both
kind of like the way Marvel films are
right they they have they're the top
tier films nowadays that we're just
spoiled with because we get so much from
them
they fuse the visuals with the sound and
then you get epicness like Titanic or or
you know E.T or something
so as an indie filmmaker
focus on your sound when you go into
post-production and then focus on your
color grade from scratch not using a Lut
because if you're just going to use a
Lut then you're almost cutting yourself
short when you can really go in in
customize and characterize that color
for your film
so once you focus on sound design
there's uh not say controversy some
people agree with this some people don't
agree with this
iadr all my films and the reason why I
ADR that is there's a pro and con the
con is you lose a little bit of
performance
the pro is you get that sound quality
that's just unmatched so I ADR all of my
films from scratch and I treat audio in
a film like I would a song where you
separate the stems and your vocals so
then you're able to control the
grasshopper noises the car driving by
the the bird flying by and the person
talking you're able to adjust Infuse all
of these sounds like a blanket compared
to recording which you captured from
film and just laying it on top of the
blanket like a sandwich there's a very
different audible experience that you
feel going that route
now because I ADR you lose a little bit
of performance but in quality you gain
five points and performance you lose two
points so you're still up three and for
me it's worth it because even when
you're on set you're not worried about
waiting for the sound guy to record the
sound or to adjust and get in place
because when you're doing indie films
it's all about time it's all about time
I don't even use the board that says
okay scene one take three I don't do any
of that because I know I'm going to ADR
and I know I'm going to do all the sound
in post I know what Clips are going well
so when I shoot I'm shooting as I'm
editing so I know exactly how I'm going
to edit the next shot so I don't I don't
have to do these long long takes so now
that all of that's edited in post you
got your sound design you got your audio
your color grades done now you have a
completed film
now once that's done somebody would say
well hey go get someone you trust to
watch it and get their feedback
I don't do that
because if I'm painting a picture I'm
not asking you to say hey should I add
this red color here nah I'm the one
painting right now it's different if you
have a 100 million dollar film you got
to make sure that the audience receives
it well so you can recoup that money but
if you're self-financing
then
you almost have
this
promise to your inner self that like you
have to create what you see
so I don't wait for someone's approval
no agent no manager no casting director
no producer
no executive
to tell me that the Final Cut Is the
Final Cut
I don't wait for the approval to tell me
that I can go make it I just make it so
once I'm finished with the film and I
watch it I'll watch it with my brother
and I'll say okay
kind of go over it's like okay no that
was good or if we if something is so
jarring after sitting it with it for six
months editing or three months we're
like all right we got to take that out
then yes we'll take it out but as far as
reshooting
um and just changing the whole feel of
the movie whatever comes over me as I'm
creating that's what the universe gave
me to paint and what it's said to do at
that time because you got to remember
like when you create a film it's your
film
it's not Johnny's Vision because if it
was Johnny's Vision then Johnny would go
right and create that film it's your
vision so be confident and comfortable
with what you create and know that it's
okay it's okay for you to create it's
okay for you to be great it's okay for
you to be the best version of yourself
it's okay to be happy it's okay for you
to mess up it's okay to to not succeed
on your first try it's okay to get up
after you got knocked down it's okay to
fail it's okay to succeed it's okay to
be who you are as a human being it's
okay and film is not the end-all be-all
life goes on Beyond film
film is what you do film is what you
create film is the the piece of you that
you give out to the world but film is
not who you are
I love that I love too that you said
that it's okay to succeed because I
think sometimes people feel guilty
yeah you don't feel like sometimes
you're good enough you don't feel
confident in yourself
to say
I can be successful too
I can do what Spielberg did I can be
that too
and I think you know when they talk
about like something like imposter
syndrome or anything like that like no
it's it's okay to be like yeah I can
make movies I can do it well
I I can do what they can do at a high
level I can do that it's okay because
cocky is only cocky if you're not able
to back it up
confidence is knowing that you already
did it and you can do it again and
you're going to need confidence to get
you where your vision is at because a
vision is only you seeing what is
possible if you stick to the plan and
you go and get after it that's all it is
so
when I say hey it's okay
it's okay to love yourself right it's
okay to like yourself it's okay to uh
appreciate what you accomplished like
there's a lot of times where somebody
would say
wow man you did an incredible job
and my response used to be
oh thanks man I'm just trying to get
like you but that's such a [ __ ]
response because in reality your
response it's okay to be like thank you
I put a lot of work I put a lot of
effort into that thank you I I
appreciate that you acknowledge that
thank you compared to not letting
yourself
enjoy that praise not to say to get full
of yourself but when someone compliments
you on your work it's okay to accept it
and not have to deflect it it's okay to
be great it's okay like I don't think we
hear that enough it's okay hey if you're
not good enough at something right now
put the effort in to get better and be
good enough but you don't have to be
good enough to someone else you have to
be good enough to yourself
so when you look in the mirror and
you're like man I'm happy with what I
see then you've succeeded in life
and that goes back to film it's like hey
you're good enough just keep swinging